hey good humans if you didn't know we
recently dropped a human good
surface-level collection at human good
Ellie calm and we're running out really
fast so make sure to stick around after
the video for a special promo code till
then enjoy this episode the USA
celebrates its heritage and identity as
a nation of immigrants what adds to the
diversity is the Asian American
population that traces its roots to more
than 20 countries in Asia each having a
different culture and a unique
characteristic in this episode of odd
man out let's see how easy it is for the
moon to figure identity we brought
together 7 Asians blindfolded I'm Asian
I'm Asian I am Asian I'm Asian I'm
Mexican one is a liar if the group
discovers who the liar is they'll split
a cash prize if the liar survives they
win the entire prize this is odd men oh
hi my name is crystal and I'm the first
person in line hi my name is Josh and
I'm the second person in line my name is
Brianna
my name is Aldi and I am the fourth
person in line and I'm Erin I am the
fifth person in line
my name is Michelle I'm the sixth person
in line I'm Preet and I'm the seventh
person in line
I'll start no shoes inside the house
plain and simple I think I mean most
Asian parents probably have dad I don't
know if this was like specific to
Filipinos they always said like not to
sleep with your feet facing the door
because the ghosts can take you or
something like that we had it you don't
sleep facing okay my strategy going into
the game is trying to ask about
different cultural nuances that people
have experienced because a lot of people
like Asian culture a lot of people like
Asian food a lot of people like Asian
women where any of you guys born in your
native countries no I'm dead boy I'm a
third generation I was born in Whittier
so it's like really white there but my
parents came from India and yeah they
were just here to come for a better life
so can we talk about like thinking that
you're not Asian friends did get that
you
had to do they didn't get that I liked
spam oh I love spam one thing I didn't
get any time I could spend a night am I
like not Asian friends house period my
white friends I know some of them like
if they would get into arguments with
their parents and they would argue back
really hard and I was thinking myself I
would never do that when when why people
call their parents by their first name I
personally thought the mole was going to
be like this white like anime lover I
did think them always why I did think
the mobile of why yes um just because I
have like a lot of friends and family I
like our Asian but they are married to
someone that usually is white so just
going off of I guess like prior judgment
I kind of just made that made that call
does everyone speak in their native
tongue fluently I am not fluent I can
understand or do you guys have like a
Asian name yes my name is the boy
someone here hasn't spoken yeah I feel
like that would be a good indication of
like just me like being like the quiet
one in the group I felt like that kind
of just like gave it away that I wasn't
like telling the truth my parents are
like whitewashed so it's like I barely
like I'm not doing in our native
language but do they give you a name I
have a Oh American name is just Brianna
yeah I was like I feel like every Asian
has a Asian name oh where you know what
ethnicity I'm Japanese oh yeah
Japanese one when you celebrate dear
I didn't think I'd be as nervous as I
was but once they started asking like
the tougher questions I kind of was like
trying to think fast if any of you guys
been back to like or have been to your
native countries really well for those
of you who have been when with the last
time that you went I went 2013 because
my sister just got married to a white
boy
all the stereotypes that were discussed
was definitely valid questions however I
don't think that's like the best way to
judge if someone is Asian or not
I vote for Josh because it was very
quiet I would think that the mall didn't
want to reveal himself too much a lot of
answers weren't too detailed I hate to
be stereotypical but it was the way that
he sounded I feel like Mexicans and
Asians are kind of like we have a lot of
similarities you feel like you're kind
of in the middle oh I'm like Chinese but
I'm an American so it's like which
culture are you more so Josh coming
about like when there's a disagreement
with your parents house I usually go oh
dude honestly man it's my parents way or
the highway
like what happens if like you really
pissed them off um like when you were
younger
me growing up I just saw a stark
difference between how my Asian friends
act around parents versus my non Asian
friends act around their parents we were
pretty like American I tore I mean I
grew up pretty Americanized so like like
I never really had too much of a
disagreement with my parents I would
always kind of just like fall the way
chrysella
was lost every parent dad told you but
they loved you I just felt like he was
trying to steer the conversation away
from him so just going off of that I
felt like he was definitely the mole I'm
actually kind of estranged from my
parents but like I'm kind of like trying
to rebuild with my mom she used to never
say that she loved me but now every time
that we do talk she does because it's
kind of complicated and if you guys ever
get a real big conflict does uh do they
ever apologize Lawlor no never I mean my
parents and that's partially why I'm
kind of estranged from especially my dad
like that's why I'm kind of history my
parents are divorced by the way which
was unheard of my Filipinos are Catholic
and they like don't divorce
I don't wanna be racist ah in my
perception a lot of like white families
go through the like divorce but also she
just sounded very like Americanized
what's the most Cambodian thing about
you
well we would go the we dozen years in
April every year we have a baby festival
what's your favorite Cambodian food as a
bulk sauce do you have you heard of it
what is it Hulk sauce for maybe fish oh
no that's like the one thing I can't
boys can never say because it's like it
smells bad it looks bad you said that
your third generation right sorry no I'm
first generation okay I said third by
accident okay I'm first generation so
your parents immigrated here yes back in
1986 in 1990 okay and me ya know when he
said he was third generation and then he
backed up and said oh no I'm first
generation that was kind of a red flag
to me I meant to say third generation
Christian because my family was Hindu
before I meant to say first generation
American after she talked about the
relationship with her parents raised a
little doubt in my mind we have three
people that look to my left or giving
just such great answers with my boy Josh
which is kind of piggybacking off those
answers in terms of being like estranged
or cutting them out it's not something
that you typically hear when it comes to
Asian families I do think that not
fitting into those stereotypes is what
got me out did you guys ever like talk
to your parents about like your mental
health growing up no no that wasn't ever
part of our culture but I feel like I
mean yeah they're very like what does
that even mean like therapy no but I
feel like you know times are changing
and like I was gonna just talk about it
with them though they're always there to
understand but did you ever have the
talk like the birds and the bees talk
with no no yeah yeah
did your parents let you like date in
high score even like middle school no
because it was more of like a like you
weren't ready type of thing my parents
were always like don't they don't they
don't think growing up and then now I'm
like okay I didn't date and now I'm like
single and there
okay like yo where my grandchildren are
you guys until like any like Asian
trends I guess I mean if tick-tock is
the trade I guess ailing I do you like
kpop I'll be jest but some of the older
ones like Girls Generation I like them
and then Super Junior I mean I'm sure
you're a fan of like the any song you
know that to anyone
there's like some trend going on like
people doing videos of like didn't you
know like this thing ok I'm not like
super into kpop it's a kpop you should
know that though it comes up on music
then y'all listen to it I'm not too sure
who any of those people we're just
saying your parents are from they're
from India but we live in Ontario
California oh but we're in India Gujarat
no wonderly no it's very good job what
are your parents names
my parents yeah my mom's name is
actually Spanish so her name is Leona
but she goes by ena now and then my
dad's name is Ashish my parents have
super white names actually it's Ellen
and Dennis a part of me yes and then um
someone next to me asked Oh what are
their Asian names and I was like oh gosh
I don't even know in their birth names
uh I actually don't yong-jin and my
mom's is I'm not really sure so just say
that noise you know on the arm here if
you guys want to feel what I'll have you
know yeah
is that a thing yeah I mean like I had
to use Syria test to defend myself
because I wanted to be sure that I was
gonna win let's say they'd never seen my
face and they're only talking to me they
would think I'm white and that was the
reason why I was voted off because I
don't it's happened to who like too much
I got a surfer dude I grew up in the
suburbs of war again so
all right I think we got them I feel
like we got I don't think so would you
think it was Josh bro I swear my man
like I definitely thought she was
Japanese the way she kind of spoke and
the way she kind of carried her soul I
just assumed she was a quiet Japanese
girl last semester I did take Japanese
class I could speak like a little bit
I'm not like fluent I wanted to see if I
was able to distinguish people what
differentiates people or as well as you
know what experiences have they gone
through that I can also relate to yeah I
feel very comfortable talking about my
recent ethnicity because yeah it matters
oh hey good humans thank you for
watching this episode of odd man out
make sure to check out our new human
good surface level collection at home
when could Ellie comm we have amazing
new bags accessories shirts sweatshirts
sweatpants etc also you can use the
special promo code hash tag surface and
get a discount on your entire purchase
and don't wait for too long because the
code expires 48 hours after the release
of the video thank you for watching this
episode and you have 47 hours 59 minutes
and 50 seconds left 49 48 47 46 45 I'd
always been self-conscious of my nose
and I like paying my parents like no no
absolutely not I got plastic surgery I
got plastic surgery I got
surgery I got plastic surgery I got
plastic surgery I got plastic surgery I
got plastic surgery I got plastic
surgery one of them is a liar
[Music]